Châu chình trên thế hi lòng giản, học sinh là huy hai muốn điểm giao tìm này thế lòng trông tay.
hình trụ tác và hay giả nhìn độ. Thì bắt đầu, chúng ta sẽ bắt đầu từ 1 nhìn độ.
Tây độ xe đúng không? Thì đó, chắc khi của chúng ta đang là chẳng thái khí.
Chắc là chắc là chắc là chắc là cái lợi bất đi.
Nhìn lượng của nó và một cái tính mặt tung thức bằng mà,
để xe nhìn hà tế để khi đó nó lấy với chẳng thái gì các bạn.
Vậy là cái nhìn độ xa đi. Và đây chỉ là nhìn độ,
nương tụ của chúng ta hay khách cho nó hay nó là nhìn độ và hồi nó.
Để chờ và tại cái mất như độ hồi này,
hả các nhìn độ nương tụ, chắc khi của chúng ta sẽ mắt đầu nương tụ
và khi đó thì như lượng của ta, lấy đi,
lất đi được là mạnh đi, nó sẽ mặt nó đến mở nó an nhạc.
Và sau đó, tế tụ, khi đó là độ hồi,
quan quan từ chất khi chuyển trên lợi rồi, nó sẽ tế tụng giả nhìn
về nhìn độ của nóm trời.
Hãy khác, đây chỉ là nhìn độ nông đọc của nó.
Để chờ, tế tạng như độ nóm trời, chúng ta lại tế tụng là mạnh để làm sao.
Tụi ta lấy bất đi nhìn độ quý và nằm gà nhìn mở.
Lấy cho lấy khi đó, từ chất lợi, nó bếng nhìn trên lợi.
Và quá trình này khi chúng ta biết đến chất lợi thì quá trình lợi này nhìn sẽ kéo lại xuất.
Trình máy khoảng lần thế sau, lấy cho tế tế là toàn bộ,
cái mơ lụ thì và hứng nào cái chú trên chúng ta chuyển thể.
Tụi chất khi chất lợi, lấy chất lợi, và các bạn cần phải liều ý.
Có có ở gì cần là có bạn có thông ơn gì?
Cảm ơn như thế, hả, thì in pho lo ngay thì có thể xem tiếp được video tiếp theo.